[Music]
hi sir
please
yeah
are you okay hi my name is Andres we
need to know if you've had if you have
any drugs or weapons on board
no I have no contracts or weapons are
you sure I'm sure yeah yeah you can
check everyone oh I just got fishing
here
okay can I get your name please a Tim
Sherlock okay
[Music]
thank you
to the captain and
um this this fishing company that saved
my life I mean um
what do you say I I just so grateful I'm
alive and uh
and uh
I did really didn't think I'd make it
you know so um thank you thank you so
much
the health was was pretty bad for a
while I was pretty hungry and
um and I I didn't think I'd make it
through the the storm but now I'm really
doing good
[Music]
that dog is is something else I sort of
found me in the middle of Mexico I tried
to find a home for maybe three times and
she just kept following me onto the
water she's she's a beautiful animal I
I'm just grateful she's alive
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]